[Music]
which drugs help against covid19
it's the top goal for medical
researchers around the world
we have already developed several
effective vaccines but a cure has not
yet been found
why is it so difficult
so far doctors have tried drugs that
have already been used for
other viral diseases like hiv ebola sars
and influenza
sometimes they can help but they are not
the breakthrough medical experts are
hoping for
what we do know is that how well a drug
works depends above all
on when it is administered
in the early stage when the virus enters
the body and multiplies
or a later phase when the body reacts
with inflammation
and immune defenses it is problematic
because
if you have a patient you don't really
know what to do
and everybody tries the best and they
observe the patient and they
observe the symptoms but there is no
standard
recommendation so far
hospitals around the world are gaining
experience with covet 19
and they're gathering data in the hope
that it'll soon be possible to do more
than just protect
healthy people with a vaccination
hello and welcome to your covet 19
special i'm chris colbert in berlin
vaccination programs around the world
are the strongest defense against the
spread of the coronavirus
but treating patients who have fallen
ill has been a lot more challenging
some doctors have used existing drugs
against covet 19 but the medical
evidence of effectiveness
is often lacking another possibility is
to use antibodies
jaban's two guy pharmaceuticals has
applied for regulatory approval
of a coronavirus treatment that combines
two
antibodies it follows trials in japan
earlier i spoke to clemens ventna head
of the shebing clinic in munich
and before we talked about the current
treatment of covet 19 cases i asked him
what it was like handling germany's
first coronavirus patient
almost one and a half years ago
actually patient zero was
without any excitement so we just did
what
any doctor would have done so the
patient got a little bit oxygen
uh a little bit inhalation not even
a real infusion so
at this moment we just used supportive
care
in the best sense but did not treat this
patient in a specific way
actually the the disease weaned off
by itself after a couple of weeks
and looking at how you treat patients
today
with covet 19 infections how has it
changed
i think we have made some progress um
based on clinical trials we also
participated
um so the one thing is in the early
phase of the
covet 19 disease you can interact by
using
drugs like rendezvir but we also have
the neutralizing antibodies so spike
directed antibodies like the famous
dragon cough ii
donald trump got it and in the later
phase of the disease so second week
and further on the principle is to
suppress the inflammation
so that's the reason or that's actually
the the prime time for steroids
the prime time for uh i had six
antibodies tosilitzumab for example
and there are new developments like
gmc's half antibodies etc etc so
you see the armamentarium uh is is
broadened and
uh but still uh some some homework to be
done
not the cure for every patient at this
point
now on that antibody treatment a company
in japan says it applied for regulatory
approval
um for an antibody treatment for kovit19
is this
approach the most promising one
i think in pandemic times you have to
react in a very tiny and quick manner so
i think the approach that has been used
in in germany but also in the us
was more efficient so we have access to
these antibodies
without an official label because this
will take months and sometimes also
years so you but you don't have time to
wait
so we are just using these antibodies uh
and without label we
we tell patients about this but we have
some data from trials that they can even
reduce mortality
so that's that's reason enough for us to
uh
apply these new drugs now covet patients
have been treated with drugs for other
viral
diseases what can we draw from that
actually we also did this in the first
few weeks so typically hiv drugs
etc um i mean that's a trial and error
in the first
days of of this pandemic
time but actually we discarded these
drugs because we learned very quickly
that they have more side effects than
effects and
when you're as trained as a
physician as a as a physician also
participating clinic trials you know
what you have to do
and so this is also the story here
you know that we didn't use hiv drugs
anymore
but sometimes you just take the stuff
that's
that's at the bench if you don't have a
lot of things to offer
and this is how it happened also in this
pandemic
now if the side effects outweigh the
actual benefits how far
along are we then when it comes to
developing a medical cure
for covet 19. i mean cure is a big word
for
for covet 19. i think we we
can help patients in a very early phase
of the disease
the problem is when the patient comes to
to the emergency room after two or three
weeks
after symptom onset so these are the
real
heavy cases and sometimes even
we are not able to help young people um
i think
still a long path to go we have
learned a lot of things about
vaccination but the medical treatment
is still let's put it this way under
development and
we and others we are actively
participating for this reason in
clinical trials using new drugs for this
disease
meanwhile fewer very old patients are
being hospitalized
how does that change the work of the
doctors working in the hospitals
uh in the second and third wave of the
pandemic we had a lot of elderly
patients in our hospital
so the point was that we also had a high
fatality rate because
many of these elderly ones 80 and above
didn't
want to go on the icu
now we have few patients but the
majority
is quite young so we do everything for
them
and but we have also a non-covered wave
let's put this way
we have two more patients that have
postponed their surgery etc
so still a lot of things to be done in
the
the clinics and let's hope that the
delta wave
will not uh you know present as many
young patients that we have to treat in
the clinics in the
icu awards clemens if you had one wish
that would improve the treatment of
covet patients what would that wish be
the wish would be that there is the
magic pill
so an oral agent that can be used by the
infected people before the disease
really starts to to make complications
so the pill
the anti-covet pill that can be taken at
home this would be
my wish for for the future
infected patients with coffee 19.
let's see how long it takes until we
have that pill clements venting ahead of
the schwabbing clinic in munich
thank you for your time while research
for a drug to help covet 19 patients
continues several vaccines have already
been developed to prevent
people from catching the coronavirus
despite high effectiveness people still
have questions about the jab
like the following one for our science
correspondent derek williams
are there any ways to mitigate your
chance of developing a thrombosis
if you're vaccinated with astrazeneca
i'm going to start this answer by saying
something i've already said
many times before which is that both
trials
and hundreds of millions of recipients
show the astrazeneca vaccine is highly
effective at preventing
future infection with covet 19 and
the chances of developing the blood
clots that have been associated with a
vaccine
are extremely rare the exact numbers
are kind of hard to interpret but the
european medicines agency says that
over the course of both doses about
one recipient in 100 000
develops the side effect so it's a very
uncommon occurrence that chance is so
much smaller than the chance of a
serious
outcome if you contract covet 19
certainly for older people
that there's a very clear benefit in
getting the astrazeneca vaccine
because vaccine-induced thrombosis is so
rare
we're still learning about it but we
think we figured out the mechanisms that
cause it
and and that coupled with simple
awareness
is now playing a big role in reducing
the dangers for those
who do develop the condition because
it can be treated if doctors recognize
it quickly
symptoms of it can include severe
headaches or blurred vision
persistent pain and an extremity or in
the abdomen
shortness of breath or the development
of unexplained bruising
around the injection site and and those
symptoms usually occur
between 4 and 30 days after vaccination
i couldn't find any advice about how to
mitigate your chances of developing the
rare side effect
which there's no surprise there since
we're still unable to predict
even who might be vulnerable but being
aware that a thrombosis can occur
and vigilant about how it presents that
can go a long way
towards helping you if you turn out to
be one of the very few people
who are affected